nouvelle charge de nancy pelosi contre
donald trump
la chef des démocrates au congrès a
présenté un projet de loi afin de
pouvoir remplacer un président s'il se
trouve dans l'incapacité de remplir ses
fonctions même si pour cette dernière il
ne s'agit pas de trump difficile de ne
pas faire le lien avec l'actuel
locataire de la maison blanche
compte tenu de sa récente contamination
aux colis de 19 il ne s'agit pas du
président trump il fera face au jugement
des électeurs mais il montre la
nécessité pour nous de créer un
processus pour les futurs présidents
tout au long de l'histoire de la mairie
nos dirigeants créer et renforcer les
garde-fous de la constitution pour
assurer la stabilité et la continuité du
gouvernement en temps de crise le 25e
amendement crée une voie permettant de
préserver la stabilité
si un président souffre d'un problème
physique ou mentale un valdes en est
incapable d'exercer les pouvoirs et les
devoirs de sa charge et de transférer
ses pouvoirs
l'aptitude d'un président à exercer ses
fonctions doit être déterminée par la
science et les faits cette législation
s'applique au futur président mais elle
nous rappelle la nécessité d'agir en
fonction de la santé du président actuel
une annonce qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir le principal intéressé qui en a
profité pour tacler joe biden son
adversaire dans la course à la
présidence nancy pelosi la folle se
penche sur le 25e amendement afin de
remplacer joe biden par kamala harris
les démocrates veulent que cela se fasse
rapidement car joe l'endormi n'est plus
dans le coup
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
démocrates temps de remettre en cause la
légitimité du président américain en
2019 ils ont mené la procédure qui a
abouti au procès en destitution de
donald trump
ce dernier était accusé d'avoir fait
pression sur le président ukrainien la
fin du rire une enquête contre le fils
de son rival
joe biden un procès dont donald trump
est sorti victorieux soutenu par la
majorité républicaine du sénat
reste à savoir si cette nouvelle
tentative de l'anticiper le
10 pourrait fragiliser un peu plus
donald trump déjà nettement en
difficulté dans les sondages à moins
d'un mois de l'élection présidentielle